هذه أخبار ضخمة يقول العلماء
إنهم التقطوا لأول مرة
صورة للقلب النابض
لمنتصف مجرتنا مجرة ​​درب التبانة إلقاء
نظرة ، هذا ثقب أسود هائل
في منتصف المجرة كل هذا
الضوء من حوله  الثقب الأسود هو
الجزء المظلم في المنتصف ، كل ذلك
الضوء من حوله هو ضوء منحني بفعل
قوة الجاذبية لهذا الذي هو
خارج المخططات ضخمة بشكل لا يصدق. كيف
حصلوا على هذه الصورة
استخدموا ثمانية تلسكوبات متطورة للغاية
حول العالم 80 مختلفة
مئات العلماء الذين
يعملون لفترة طويلة يتجمعون قليلاً
في وقت واحد ، تخيل محاولة التقاط
صورة لجبل به الكثير من
الغيوم المارة حيث يمكنك
الحصول على القليل هنا قليلاً
ولكن بعد ذلك تقوم بتجميعها كلها  معًا
وفجأة تقولون آه هذا ما
يبدو عليه الجبل وهذا ما
فعلوه هنا فعلوه على مسافة هائلة
للحصول على هذه الصورة الآن لماذا
يهم هذا الأمر لأنني  سوف
نعطيهم فكرة عن كيفية تأثير
ذلك على عمل نجوم مجرتنا
في المجرة ، والتي تبلغ كتلتها حوالي 4 ملايين
ضعف كتلة الشمس ، مما يمنحك
فكرة عن حجمها ، ولكنها أيضًا
تبلغ حوالي
27000 ضوء.  بعد سنوات ، لذا إذا كنت ترغب في
الذهاب لزيارتك ،
فمن الأفضل أن تحزم وجبة غداء